a partir de este sábado estas calles en
la ciudad de nancy al noreste del país
estarán vacías a partir de las 6 de la
tarde
finalmente verifica si la medida es
efectiva yo prefiero esta medida a un
confinamiento durante el día o hacer el
para mí es ridículo no importa si
empieza a las 6 oa las 8 no va a cambiar
nada por el contrario forzar a más
personas a ir al comercio al mismo
tiempo el nuevo toque de queda de 6 de
la tarde a 6 de la mañana aplicará para
estos 15 departamentos donde las
infecciones por coronavirus son más
altas en otras regiones el toque de
queda actual desde mediados de diciembre
será mantenido desde las 8 de la noche
la medida surgida por algunos alcaldes
ante la preocupación por un eventual
colapso de sus sistemas de salud muchos
creen que la situación sólo empeorará
luego de las fiestas de fin de año
el alcalde de nancy sin embargo cree que
medidas más estrictas deben ser
impuestas para minimizar la propagación
del virus esposita la cual creo que ya
es muy tarde porque esperar hasta el
inicio de enero y probablemente no es
suficiente
no estamos en el inicio del aumento de
incidencias tampoco al inicio de
incremento del número de pacientes hemos
visto esto en nancy y en el este desde
inicios de diciembre último el de som
el viernes francia reporta un poco más
de 19 mil casos en 24 horas lo cual es 4
veces mayor a lo fijado por el gobierno
cuyo objetivo es de menos de 5000 casos
diarios el aumento de infecciones
también significa que los teatros los
cines y los conciertos no reabrirán el 7
de enero como se esperaba